Speaker 1: I genuinely don't know at this
point in time.
What is the belief of Stephen Bannon about
something they call decertification?
Decertification is a word that Bannon and
people like MyPillow CEO Mike Lindell, we
just know him as pillow.
What have they been?
How seriously do they believe that states
can or might decertify the 2020 election results?
This is not going to happen.
We're almost at the next election, but Steve
Bannon continues to talk about it.
So I want to play this clip for you.
People who are watching might realize Steve
Bannon is just a spitting image of Bea Arthur
at this point.
It's a very, very strange, physical appearance
of Steve Bannon, and that's sort of out of
school.
They don't really know what to make of it.
But let's focus in on what Steve Bannon says
here.
Listen to what he says
Speaker 2: of these electors.
And that's what I remember.
Let's get our language very specific.
We're not asking and we've never asked for
President Trump's never asked for this movement's.
Never asked for it to change the election
and afflicted to Donald J. Trump.
That is just not the right nomenclature.
It's not the right language.
What we've asked for is very simple that only
certifiable constitutional legal chain of
custody votes from American citizens can be
counted for the November 2020 election.
Speaker 1: Now, of course, that's exactly
what happened.
There has been no evidence that votes that
should not be counted were counted.
So so far, I'm with Bannon.
Only valid votes should be counted, and we
have evidence that only valid votes were counted.
Speaker 2: Good once they're counted right
in an accurate way and real votes, not things
that came off the machines.
Although I'm not a machine, guys people know.
But once we get every
Speaker 1: remember Mike Pillow wants to sue
all machines.
Speaker 2: Oh, OK.
That's the election.
And we know now whether it is in Pennsylvania,
whether it is in, whether it's in Wisconsin,
Arizona or Georgia, those four states alone.
We understand right now and I think eventually
Nevada, Nevada and Michigan.
But those four states alone, we can move right
now, the state legislature to decertify the
decertify the electors, not to flip the election
and decertify the electors and do what the
Constitution says, flipping to the House of
Representatives where you vote by you vote
by delegation.
State by state.
And of course, we control, what, twenty six
or twenty seven of those delegations?
Speaker 1: Okay.
So again, Bannon is saying states can say
our electors weren't valid.
And then you instead of going by electoral
votes, each state gets one vote for who should
be president.
26 states out of 50 will say, We believe Trump
and then Trump becomes the president.
This is not going to happen.
First of all, we are almost at the next election.
We're what is it now, eight months of seven
and a half months from the midterms.
But putting that aside, everything Bannon
says in this clip is untrue, and I don't know
if Bannon really believes what he's saying.
There is no legal basis to decertify a state's
election or electors.
There's just it's just not a thing.
There is no provision in the United States
Constitution that says if states quote, decertify
their electors, then anything happens.
Joe Biden is president to remove Joe Biden,
he would need to die.
The 25th Amendment could be used or he could
be convicted on impeachment.
Those are the three ways that you can quote
remove the president.
And in any of those three situations, the
vice president would assume the presidency.
So what Bannon is talking about doesn't exist.
And the most important consideration here
is imagine that even though there is no such
process as the decertification, imagine some
state invented it and created it.
If a state.
Did it?
And again, what it what it means isn't even
clear, but if a state were to decertify now
in March, almost April of 2022, it would have
no legal significance.
It's not like even if you go and follow this,
imagine that four states call up.
Who do you even call?
I guess you call up the Senate.
I don't even know who do you tell you?
Call someone in D.C. and you say, Sirs and
M&Ms.
We've decertified our election from our electors
from 2020.
You think Washington, D.C. goes, Oh, OK, well,
let's just redo this thing and we'll have
each state get one vote.
Of course not.
There is no such process, and it's not in
the Electoral Count Act of 1887.
It has no provision for decertification that
the 1887 legislation or structure on which
this is all based.
So again, my question to you is, do you think
Steve Bannon really believes any of this stuff?
Make sure that you see these clips on our
Instagram, which you can find at David Pakman
show